a children's Club sponsored by the
German engineers association is touring
the Audi factory in Ingolstadt the
automaker hopes to make an impression on
the engineers of the future I'm really
interested in technology man see did you
see cars being driven but no one
actually knows how they're made the idea
behind the 45 children's clubs across
the country is to give kids a head start
in technology the original one in
nuremberg was founded by an engineer
Bordeaux a Kinger he volunteers his time
to organize experiments and excursions
that's initial vena Schuler in they
don't just sit in a classroom and listen
to a teacher to earn so now let's see
they can get personally involved helped
put together experiments experience
technology and better understand the
possibilities it offers us on the merge
cognitive technic betta desert safari
howdy shares this interest the automaker
has over 72,000 employees worldwide
every unit is highly specialized howdy
plans to produce two million cars a year
by 2020 and it will need well-trained
workers Mikael caused a higher 1,500 new
employees this year alone 350 positions
are still open contacting future
generations of workers is always an
important concern be on base base vizor
hinting glitched up for example here in
Ingolstadt we bring in up to 2,000
trainees from schools they get to visit
our workshops and get an entire week to
see how an engineer is trained in
engineering that's marked an engineer
the 20 kids from nuremberg still have a
few years to go not all of them are
convinced they'll want to manufacture
cars
it's not very exciting all you see is
how the screws are put in there could
you imagine becoming an engineer no
maybe work in an office but not in the
factory but cars have to be designed as
well maybe that could be her future
career